i'm not with espresso and all that fancy
stuff give me a burnt
ground like give me the coffee that they
give the truck drivers right because
their life is on the line
so if it's good enough for them it's
good enough for me that's how i feel
are you doing an isolation or quarantine
order nope
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
vince what's up man and living in you
know a pandemic
so this is our first time meeting i
think we have a lot of people in similar
camps that are like yo do you know vince
and
and uh i'm glad we could we could link
up who are these people
tommy the podcast i knew it was the
podcast maven himself
yeah i knew it was tommy it's always hey
come to dinner
no one wants to hang out with tommy all
day no one's hanging out talking all day
i love him though
please keep this in the cut so tommy can
see it he he knows i don't want to hang
out him
tommy calls me every probably every two
weeks
with the new ideas never the same why it
is never a follow-up uh-huh but just he
has a new idea of an amazing podcast
that will change everything
oh he wants you to join his podcast
network
i mean look i get along with tommy so if
you can get along with tommy you don't
get anybody that's
that's how i feel all right what was one
of his ideas was it just like yo you
need to start a podcast
it's always the same idea it's just a
different basketball player
and he put me on a group text with jj
redick out of nowhere hilarious
do you even know who jj reddick was of
course okay okay
but he was like do you know jj and i was
like no and then i just got a text
message to my phone uh-huh
and was jj like when's the new album
coming out or was it just like hey man
what's going on now we were talking
about um
was talking about his basketball journey
yeah via text
yeah via text because you thought
somebody in a group text you don't want
to sing you know say anything you just
ask them about themselves and people
start talking
yeah but i like jj reddick i saw her as
a documentary
they had some document about him and his
sister a minute ago like about them
growing up in the woods or something
like that uh-huh
i was a big fan of that bro the things
you know you know in a very deep way and
internet
and i don't really forget much shout out
jj reddick man i support him
have you been listening to podcasts all
the time it's my favorite thing so
there's this podcast i've been listening
to
it's a spotify original podcast called
renegades born in the usa
uh it's with none other than one of your
favorite musicians the boss
of the boss bruce springsteen and uh
president barack obama former president
barack obama even the biggest one of the
biggest musicians in the world and the
former president have to have a podcast
on spotify
but one of the things they talked about
that i thought was really interesting is
that
both of them felt like outsiders you
know
um did you feel like when you were
coming up
you know in the music scene coming from
long beach
you felt like an outsider in sort of
like the la music scene
it was a big disconnect because i didn't
have anything really in common with a
lot of the kids because like i said
we're kids at that point in time
and i come from like a long beaches you
know even though it's the hood there's
all these other things
it's extremely diverse so it's like i
always been like even though i've never
been like my friends like yeah you live
over here
you go to school with us we play sports
all these other things you're the homie
we all friends
right but going to deal with music in
los angeles and not being that it being
like
caveats to relationships and you know
this and that and that and then never
being anything with any real
implications or like of if anything
getting further anything being life or
death
i didn't understand why everything was
so such a pressure situation
it's very very cliquish and quality and
music people like you're from long beach
like you're not really nobody lost me i
never told anybody else from me
wow i didn't even know where i was
coming from so like y'all gonna see
where they are and i'll be there
so they just thought we was from l.a
nobody knew where i was coming from
that's funny because for
for me the first open mics i started
were in sacramento
and there was this feeling with all the
san francisco comics that like
yo only road comics only like comics
that aren't going to make it
start in sacramento but that's just
where i was i i lived out there and i
was going to
which is why i didn't tell anybody
because i know i made that weird
i knew it would be weird because it's
just so far like
it's long beach has a weird stigma with
it's the weird city like so it's like
you know people might not open up to you
be warm to you but
is long is artesia by long beach it's
like long beach lakewood belle flopped
in our teachers right here
uh-huh and our teacher's probably like
four or five streets like it's a really
really small city
yeah my mom used to get her eyebrows
done at a place called ziba yeah i know
you know you know
get our teeth to sit outside it's like
whenever we go to la i'd always want to
go to cool places i'd be like mom let's
go to like
anaheim she's like no we're going to go
to cerritos and um artesia
yes it's getting harder it's a large
population with long beach like
everybody pretty much acts the same in
that whole
pocket so we didn't really understand
that some of our friends were indian
grown up until we met their parents like
that's what that's about hilarious
that's one thing about long beach
everybody got the same voice as saying
we're naturally we say the same words
i'm one of our friends israel we didn't
know his mom was mexican
and then she picked us up one day and we
were so confused
yeah and we were like why didn't you
tell us and he was like what i tell you
that it's like well just
just so we know like yeah cause now i
feel like i've been like
ignoring the whole society you know yeah
so it's like you know
especially that part artesia cerritos um
bro when you pull up there like i you
know when you're just
outside like just like eating a samosa
you're like yo if people drive by you're
straight up in india
oh it's all indian people no one thing i
respect about california a lot when you
go into people's pockets
you're in a pocket like yeah the
language on the buildings change yep you
know i mean the stories change
i think that's a very very understated
part of you know this place it's dope
yeah because just thinking about the
fact that you have like these grocery
stores where
nothing is in english yeah and you know
it's not a thing that people think about
is just you know not even
yeah i think it's a beautiful thing it's
kind of cool that you can just go into a
green tunnel
and just transport it exactly yeah
exactly there's so many small places
like where i grew up at totally
you know but diversity and acceptance
was always a thing so
like i don't know i guess in a sense you
you would feel like an outsider if you
come from a place where like
everyone is outside are you trying to
break into a medium yeah even with my
music like
people would look at me or like here
i'll talk to her i'll treat people i
keep like oh this
this his story can't necessarily be true
because he's too nice of a person he
doesn't look like
yeah he would fit that bill but that's
like the point like people understand
these experiences
until you you say them and when you try
to share your experience
people might not always be receptive to
it if you're not them it's like
we live in such a weird vacuum i mean
it's kind of like how president obama
said in the podcast
america is a place for all people you
know it's it's a melting pot and it's
it's
we should lean on our diversity because
you know especially traveling the world
touring as
you know as well you'll go certain
places in certain states
and there'll be a whole bunch of people
that you never expected to see
yeah it's like i remember my first time
going to new mexico and i just was
just shocked about it like the way that
the houses looked the way the building
is going
what was in the restaurant you ever
played missoula montana i've never
played montana i've played montana
multiple times
and i'm like yo nobody's a nobody's
going to come out b people won't get it
but they they get it like
it's it's kind of dope that it's always
the place you think no one is yeah
and just like it's kind of cool knowing
that
all right there's just a bunch of
weirdos who may connect with what i'm
doing
i mean some random places that were so
just good experiences
boise ithaca like
um columbus ohio yeah
albuquerque like just the middle of
arizona cities i don't even remember
chico california like i've been so many
random places where you know yeah i've
been a chico on the ground yeah
yes it's crazy bro these experiences man
like
i just wish you know more people could
have them but one thing that
is being shown to a podcast and you know
just how far reaching we couldn't be
from a digital space is
i think we're in a point moving towards
that everyone can
experience a little bit of this based on
things that they digest and like
relationships that you can make like it
doesn't take much to start a podcast it
doesn't take much to start you know
a music career comedy crew just got to
kind of have that kind of faith
even though we don't know each other and
this is our first time meeting
i was telling you this like right when
we came in you have a very dark
comedic sensibility like i actually see
you more as a comic than
musician i hear that a lot i think i'm
like a pretty bright like you know
bubbly person to be honest but
you consider yourself to be an optimist
man all the time i get the nihilism
thing a lot but i don't really even
necessarily know like what that means
like because
nothing has any meaning because you have
to apply meaning to things yeah like as
the world changes and stuff like that so
i don't really look at it as if you know
since there's no meaning there's no hope
it's like if you can see somebody like
you know we name things we create things
and we
change them as we go like nobody really
knows what they're doing so if nobody
knows what they're doing
then that should allow you enough you
know freedom to kind of
figure out your own path or kind of
figure out what you want to do in life
because a lot of the times man i feel
like people just
kind of fall victim to kind of being
like hopeless or like distraught or like
feeling despair and like all that cute
[ __ ] if i know for a fact that nothing
means anything i'm going to go find
something and i'm going to make it
whatever i want it to be
and i'm going to mind my business if
you're trying to get in the zone
and you're about to go to the studio or
you're just feeling like
you're a little blocked and you want to
write something
who's on your spotify playlist like who
are you listening to to kind of
put you in a place where like all right
i feel inspired to go
make music as crazy as it sounds i
promise you
i never listen to music i get it no i
get it i was in the podcast a lot yeah
but like
i'm more of a writer type person than a
musician i'm not really like i don't
know anything about
i don't know any instruments i don't
know keys i barely even know how many
bars it is in the song like
it's so funny that you listen to
podcasts it's it's so consistent that
like
musicians love podcasting comedy all
that sort of stuff
and comedians just want to be musicians
like well i feel like i feel like you
need a break from
your reality but that's that's that's
creativity in the sense like
when you're when you're looking into
something creative you're looking for a
break in your reality
well one thing i tell people all the
time is like you know everybody's normal
like no one's special
and i think no one being special allows
everyone to be significant if that makes
sense
so it's like if you think about
everyone's daily track everyone's daily
journey
you can't just listen to songs all day
you kind of have to know what's current
in the world was current and so that's
one thing i didn't know when i was on
tour
i don't know what's going on right so i
can you you can't gauge kind of what's
going on like it's more important to
listen to people than to listen to music
totally agree bro it's one of the best
things about touring
like you know i travel solo so when i
land at an airport and i'm just like in
a taxi just talking to
the taxi driver first of all they have a
way more interesting story than anybody
in the city
exactly like they got wild stories and
then two
they'll kind of tell you what's what
with what's going on like rent's too
high
rents this blah blah blah this is what's
going on with the mayor this is what's
happening in the city people here in
boston are this like
touching the city that way is way more
important to me
than just like doom scrolling twitter
when you become too famous and you're
too disconnected from people
things change yeah we don't understand
that that's why
yeah like the second you stop talking to
people and just being around
people in that city and just kind of get
a feel for where they're at and what
they're doing
um yeah bro you just like you completely
lose touch
i have this thing they should ask every
politician how much is milk right now
like whoever's running for mayor right
now in new york be like yo how much is
milk right now and they should have
three answers they'd be like this is how
much it is at the bodega
this is how much it is at like whatever
the grocery store that you got
and this is how much it is at the costco
over the bridge in jersey some of these
people like they have no
clue you know what i mean
[Music]
what's your origin story like where did
you how did you get into music
i actually needed a little break from
some things okay so i had to move to uh
atlanta kind of for a cultural reset so
to say all right
until you know i was able to return some
personal reasons
hey man you know okay you know a lot of
a lot of you know just having fun you
know being a kid gotcha
and um when i came back a lot of things
that transpired
that i didn't kind of like so i was
trying to switch paths so to say
okay so i had this kid that was our
friend his name was uh
dejean you know he had that one kid it's
like a weirdo yeah and
he's kind of like not like everybody
else like we always liked him but he was
like one of those kids he used to live
by
it was this kid named chuck he had a
studio he had a house on janus
they was recording and doing a little
stuff and i would hang out with him it
was never something i cared about no
horrible okay
um chuck had good beats though but at
that point we were kids we were horrible
you know you're not good with your kid
yeah for the most part if you are then
you know us and this isn't the story
i was hanging out with them a lot trying
to stay out of trouble whatever they
took us to l.a because he was meeting
sid
for something they were doing like songs
and stuff and they're like oh man
uh we're doing a party at neck brace
party
and uh they was gonna get like five
hundred dollars a piece or something
like that and i was like i can do that
wow and and that's that's what happened
and here we are did you always have this
voice
like i feel like you and dave chappelle
sonic we have such a great distinct
voice you know it's funny it's a video
on youtube like it's like a fight at the
school i went to
yeah and i said something in the back of
the camera and one of the comments is is
that vince staples
i was real upset yeah so i pretty much
had the same voice my whole
life especially with comedy having a
distinct like
octave sound is so important yeah like
you know i mean it sells the joke at
least when i saw it looking like
a joke totally having a distinct tone of
voice in any medium really but you're
selling yourself no matter what you're
selling did you know you were good
did you think like when you first
started were you good i'm not really i
mean i was better than everybody else
but i wasn't
good how did you know you were better
like you just
cause you would record and you could
immediately that's horrible wow
well i mean when you're a kid you don't
have much of a life story you know what
i mean so it's like there's nothing
really talking about a lot of my friends
all surrounded with just people and
like when you're that young you have
literally nothing to talk about now the
funniest part about that is that i
didn't
make music about myself ever until like
i should just like whatever the song was
like
they would tell me what to wrap about or
tell them like whatever the context of
the song was like this is the name of a
beat
and this is what the song is about just
because at that point i was just buying
time and hanging out before i had to go
back home because i never really took it
seriously like wanted to really be a
rapper
it was just like a pastime or a hobby or
something did it all happen accidentally
yeah 100 really i had never tried to
like really make it
like for me i was um in high school i
was a speech and debate kid
and i was kind of a knucklehead in class
and my teacher shout out to miss
takeuchi
i'm actually still trying to find you
miss t wherever you are just slide in my
idea and call
call me um she's retired now but miss
takeuchi was basically saying you
interrupt in class all the time
i'll not send you to the principal's
office if you just join
the public speaking team it's a good
teacher yeah she was really good and
when i'd go to tournaments i could just
make fun of the other kids and their
arguments
and like the all the judges were
basically just parents who had to drive
their kids to the tournaments
and um they would always give me like 10
to 15 points higher they're like yo
thank you for
you know making it fun yeah just like
it's super boring yeah
you light it up you have like 15 year
olds arguing about you know like
fiscal judiciary committee policy and
like a city and we don't know what we're
talking about and so i was like nobody
knows what they're talking about
your dad is one of the judges that's a
conflict of interest and uh i don't know
why we're talking about
you know fixing the city when like the
gym that we're arguing in as like a
a leak in the roof how did that
translate into
comedy and how did that translate into
your comedic style and time again all
that good stuff did it help you
or did it hurt you more at the beginning
so i graduate high school my freshman
year college
every every kid in the dorms has lime
wire and kazaa on their computer and
they're just downloading
um everything i obviously wasn't because
i'm
i just like abide by the rules yeah
that's illegal and i don't do anything
illegal so it was all other people and i
in fact i witnessed that
you told him to stop and i said stop it
i and actually my nickname in the dorms
was um
dcma take down notice so
everybody in the dorms was was
downloading stuff and
um one of my roommates downloaded
all these stand-up comedy specials and
it was chris rock's never scared he was
wearing this like purple velour suit
and i just remember seeing everything
that he was joking about like he was
talking about
the war and politics and and president
bush and
all these things that i thought you
could never say and i was like wow he's
doing funny speech and debate
and everybody's like what and i'm like
he's doing forensics he's just making it
funny
he has an argument he's just saying it
in a funny way and um
it kind of clicked for me in that moment
and i didn't have any
pop culture reference to stand-up comedy
like my parents were immigrants they
didn't let me
watch cable tv i didn't get to see any
of that stuff so i googled how to become
a comedian it says call your local
comedy club i google
the local comedy club at the sacramento
punch line there was this very famous
comedian performing
i didn't know who he was so i called the
club i was like hi
you know i'm hustling i'm a i'm an
aspiring comedian
i was wondering if i could open for dave
chapoli this weekend
and they were like what and i'm like on
the website it says there's a comedian
named dave chappelle he's performing i
heard that if you want to perform you
just call the club and you ask to
have a guest set or an opening set and i
just kept calling and they were they
they kept hanging up on me they're like
are you the dave chapley kid we're not
talking to you or whatever
and then i ended up going down to the
club like tuesday or wednesday and i was
like hey you guys kept hanging up on me
and i'm trying to
perform and they're like you're the dave
chappelle kid i'm like yeah and he's
like his name is dave chappelle
we thought you were like prank calling
yeah and then they're like just
just show up to the open mic night so i
just started going to the open mic night
but
i was actually too scared to go to the
open mic night so i just went i bought a
ticket and then like i sat
in the front row and a bunch of the
comedians were awful and i figured i'm
like well if
if they can be this bad yeah like i can
do it too
yeah i can be bothered about that good
yeah it's always because i feel like a
lot of times people are passionate about
things you know necessarily not with a
skill set especially at the beginning of
it
yeah but a lot of the skill set is just
you know dedication and understanding
and kind of taking yourself out of it
because if you know you're not good then
you'll get better but a lot of people
just don't know that they kind of don't
have it right away
do you feel like if if the first people
you met
were really good you might have not done
it of course
but if they're like had you met tyler
like had the first person you met with
tyler
would have been like yo maybe i
shouldn't do this or maybe tyler's talk
all the time tyler was horrible then too
really he was the best one probably
because he was the oldest but when i met
him
if you ask tyler about anything from
that point in time he'll be like i hate
that stuff
really because you know over time you
get access to certain things you learn
certain things and now tyler's like a
you know a musician musician at that
it's like you're an aspiring musician
then you're a musician
and it's a big difference between those
two so i think at that point in time
like
i never was like discouraged or anything
like that like i don't honestly think i
cared enough to ever like be affected in
that way is it weird seeing your friends
become famous i think it didn't bother
me because they were never like my
friends
like only because i come from so far
away so to me
i didn't care about the music i just
didn't want to be at home right so
i was trying to find like an escape
route we actually ended up living at my
grandmother's house
in watts so i was taking a blue line and
then i was taking the red line it was
easier to get to l.a
you know every single like uh public
transit
yeah man i feel like some of the best
comedy comes from the craziest [ __ ] that
you've seen
on public transportation people don't
understand man like there's some really
characters there's full-on like fights
there's like
there's like uh series regulars that
come on
if you want to survive on public
transportation you have to
build a relationship with the smokers
because the smokers lived there
and they kind of controlled the whole
thing like it was this one dude that was
always on the blue line i can tell when
he was hiring when he wasn't
if he's high get on his car because the
police not coming to check tickets right
if he's in there a while you know he
might piss in the corner he might fall
asleep you know
you save 1.50 like you learned some life
lessons on that train
so what's this last year been like for
you i'm i'm a homebody already i like
staying at home so
mean i never had a home really growing
up so i was like outside doing something
i had no business doing are you giving
me a couch
and like a tv and like some wi-fi you'll
never get me to leave
yeah bro it's been tough for me man my
whole thing like
for comedians the only way we get good
is by being
on the road in front of people on the
road or in the city like
this past year for me the benefit has
been i've been around the kids a bunch
you know um i have a three-year-old and
a one-year-old we had a pandemic baby
but the downside has been like
this whole superpower this thing that i
feel like is my whole identity
i just haven't been able to do so like a
bunch of us comics were kind of like
yo are we still even good like can we
even still do this do you think it's
more about life experience though or
experience in the space
because like for me i've i think for
five six years like and i'm not even
exaggerating we probably toured
90 percent of the year from the time i
was like 19 to like i was 20 something
wow you toured that hard like we i think
we probably had three tours a year
like and you wouldn't you wouldn't even
like come home you had an apartment or
whatever that you wouldn't even
i was funny i would come home and then
move you know
but it's like i had a couple of deaths
in the family and i you know you take
those breaks to decompress whatever
right and then that rolled right into
this
and at first it was kind of hard i've
recorded like probably my engineers had
like 180 something songs
since are you that prolific but you just
come up with that much music i just
record fast it's not always good but i
can make a song like five minutes i've
never really took my time to make songs
how do you know like what's your
internal compass like who do you play
the music for but
me to be honest because everybody likes
everything that's just so annoying
everybody
people like to find like the brighter
side of things and like i hate
stuff like that like you either like it
or you don't or like not even if you
like it because the wrong person likes
the right thing
it can [ __ ] your life up so you know you
kind of got to just
i think it's just staying power um
realizing what kind of i feel like means
something at the present time because
you can make this whole 2018 that's the
greatest thing you've ever heard
but if you wait six months to put it out
it doesn't matter anymore so you can't
have an ego and like you can't be too
attached to it
in the sense to where okay i made this
song at the end of the year the entire
soundscape of music changes now 80 bpm
is too fast so you have to go
i mean that that's a big thing in music
it's just the time changing because
like if even especially from a rap
standpoint like it was five new rappers
last year that most people have
forgotten about in the year before and
the year before and the year before
everyone has these moments
in time and these people are making
music previously but certain people's
success changes the trajectory of music
so when those things happen you have to
look at what you have and realize
this might not be suitable for today's
day and age is that terrifying just the
speed at which
music is changing and how do you have
staying power as a musician
because one thing i feel like we forget
sometimes like it's not about you like
even even even with comedy right it
doesn't matter how good you think the
joke is if nobody laughs nobody laughs
it could be the most
in-depth the most thoughtful most morbid
[ __ ] ever but yeah they don't get it it
doesn't matter they decide whether or
not yeah i feel like it a lot of these
younger kids you know i started making i
was 15 and i'm 27 so it's been a long
time
these kids now don't necessarily think
about themselves as much they're just
kind of having fun with when i was
younger bro and like you had a song you
coveted that song you didn't want anyone
to hear you wanted to leak that was a
thing now people are playing records on
instagram live
and if people like it on instagram live
then they'll put the song out like
it's not as precious as it was once said
to be and i think that that's a good
thing because you know
it's it's an experience it's like you
know if you all got this joke but i
don't want to tell it like one thing
about
you know dave they will try jokes out in
front of three or four people
and then 50 people 10 people and then
he'll put it in a special but yeah
he'll let it fly immediately but he
won't be like okay
this i've this is so precious i can only
try it on the biggest medium i think
that music is getting to that point now
which i think is good for like the
people that's creating it do you have a
genre of tv and movies that you really
[ __ ] with
that you're like this is my i watch
everything because it's like
rom-coms the whole thing and i love you
if it's on tv and is it interesting i'm
watching it
wow actually i was gonna i was meaning
to ask you this because you
you you love food and this says a lot
about a person
best diner do you [ __ ] with diamonds
dinos has better coffee
oh okay like i don't i'm not with
espresso and all that fancy stuff give
me a burnt
ground like give me the coffee that they
give the truck drivers right because
their life is on the line
so if it's good enough for them it's
good enough for me that's how i feel
facts
[Music]
so one of the things that we're talking
about on the renegades podcast
you know president obama and bruce
springsteen for talking about their
musical
influences and it's so weird because
when i was at the daily show jon stewart
loved bruce springsteen so i'm a child
of immigrants right growing up in the
house
all my pop culture references i'm the
eldest so i didn't have a big brother or
big sister to like kind of teach me
things right
so i remember john being obsessed with
bruce
and i started listening to like some of
his music and this is zero hype i'm just
listening to it for the first time he
always has this like deep raspy voice
like just like
man we would just we were just kids
from the city yeah and we had we crossed
over that red bridge
to the city we knew that we would leave
in that small town behind i'm like why
is this dude's voice so raspy
on the road yeah i didn't i didn't
understand
it's the outfit i didn't but i didn't
understand the whole like
man we would just we were just two kids
in a pickup truck and we
we were leaving that small town behind i
had no idea that he was the dude
that like started that character when
you listen to
richard pryor and you're like oh a bunch
of comics
yeah were influenced by him look man one
you just got to go to jersey man
it's the jeans it's the t-shirt you know
it's it's the blue springs it's the
little read
i only know about two or three songs
really but you
i think a big part of music is branding
like
i think that's the most important part
and always has been in my opinion it
plays such a large part in who you are
yeah and i think that was the thing
about a lot of dudes from that area like
things were still being created i think
in this point in time
everything's already been done for to a
certain extent you know what i mean but
when you think about your sound
what do you think it's linked to because
i feel like there's this whole class
of musicians now i can kind of see the
lineage but
you guys are just doing you before i
started making music i didn't listen to
much music
like i had never heard a lot of albums
from like a lot of the bigger artists
like you know like
you're saying with the parents thing i
come up in an area of like
uh ipod so it's like if you don't have
one of those you can have a computer to
put the songs on you had what you got at
school
it got to the point like what i knew was
like mtv jams vh1 soul
like when i started making music i
started getting into other things
and i kind of had the freedom of not
necessarily having a favorite thing
so i was able to make mistakes and kind
of force certain things but
as far as influences it's not
necessarily for me it's more so
seeing people complete their visions and
kind of sticking to them so when you see
someone's journey
and you kind of see them doing things on
their own terms and masterpiece you know
certain people it makes you feel like
you're a porter's head it makes you feel
like you're able to create your own
journey not necessarily see i want to do
that
but they did something that necessarily
hadn't been done in that scope before
and it allows you to put certain things
in music like it allows you to
see that it's okay to be truthful it's
okay to be
you know imperfect it's okay to be
vulnerable in your music in a sense
because you know
when you give a song to someone you're
not necessarily expecting them to relate
to it as much you expect them to try to
understand you
so in order to do that you have to have
you know that vulnerability you have to
have
the kind of disposition of just openness
if you don't have an openness then
you'll never be able to truly be
yourself you feel like the the music you
make and the people
like your vince staples fans do you feel
like your fans know you
because that's the one thing that i
noticed with with comedy like you know i
took a big influence from
the way kevin hart tells stories and
pryor was a storyteller chappelle's one
of the great storytellers they can kind
of build things into this long arc
my storytelling style's a little bit
different but i actually am just kind of
paying homage to what they've done
like hey this is an eight minute 10
minute 12 minute story about
you know the way i propose to my wife or
this is a 12 minute story about like
the day my my daughter was born i'm just
straight up paying homage to what they
did
so that every kind of new chapter of my
life as new things happen i can just
tell
new stories and i'm growing with the
people who like what i do
you know i think no matter what you
always kind of pay homage because
it's like a craft you know i mean like
yeah but that's elevation but at the end
of the day
it all kind of grows from one specific
thing and it's the first time it's been
you know a joke is a joke no matter how
you tell it you pay homage by telling a
story but you don't view it as
disrespectful to not tell the story the
exact same way that they did
it's also kind of crazy that nothing
really is new person at all
ever the one thing about comedy music
that connor synonymous with that
you have to kind of open up and tell the
most uncomfortable parts of something
yeah and that makes it relatable to
people because if they don't have that
experience they understand that
uneasiness yeah and that's kind of what
brings out the laughter it brings out
you know the joy and whatever you know i
feel like that's what
one of the things that you do so well
you kind of troll yourself
yeah it looks like you know what i mean
but but it's never that serious
yeah and like i do that too in a lot of
my stories where like
yeah i'm the protagonist in the story
but i'm losing yeah
everybody takes themselves so seriously
so if if you're the butt of the joke
you're kind of low status
everybody else in the story's high
status they feel like all right we're
rooting for you
you know but we're all kinda living our
life that way
we all answer to somebody you know what
i mean and we all have low moments and
you know we don't need to be picked up
when we're up we need to be picked up
during our low moments so
you know if you're vulnerable about
those low moments you know you you show
the similarities
you know one thing i tell people about
music is once you're on the stage you're
on the stage
the hardest thing is to get on the stage
once you're on the stage you have
nothing to worry about
so if you're already there how do you
connect with the people that are
probably never go to the stage you've
never had stage fright
no never really never even when you're
acting
like when you're doing the vin staples
show and you're like that's that's easy
that's way easier than rapping
wow way easier because it's not as dark
and it's not cues and stuff like that
like yeah
it's way way easier than music one of
the best thing that that's happened for
me
is fatherhood and and just having
something outside of myself
where it doesn't have to be about me
everything that we do i mean like let's
just be real we're surrounded by a crew
cameras
kids is one of the few things that i
have in my life that my wife
where they don't care about any of that
stuff i'm there to service
and serve them and be there for them in
renegades president obama spoke about
fatherhood and you know
fear of disappointment and things of
that when you're dealing with your
children
i know you just had another child yeah
so do you ever feel like
you could disappoint them or like there
are certain pressures or
how does that how does that work for you
i totally get where he's coming from
because being a dad is
the most terrifying but most beautiful
thing
i've ever done in my life like it's one
of the first times
in my life i've felt like i can't die i
know that's like morbid
i feel you 100 my mom's always she's
always on the phone with me don't say
this don't joke about this
don't piss this person off and i've
always kind of been like
i don't care i don't care and now that i
have them
like when they look at me i know they
need i don't know what it is this is
when they look at me i feel like they
need me i'm the only person that cares
about them unconditionally
obviously me and my my wife so it's a
terrifying thing because
i know that i can't mess up i have to be
there
for them they see me for who i really am
like
there's no hiding from them whereas with
show shoot whatever you know
you can you confront a little bit you
can hide with your kids know who you are
can't put it on at all no man like they
see every party
they see how not punctual you are they
see you angry they see you upset
they see what type of husband you are
you're exposed and so that's especially
when you're spending so much time in the
house with everything
totally i know you had uh an amazing
relationship with your mom
like do you want to have kids is that
something that you're looking i feel
like or
i feel like i never wanted to have kids
when i was younger
because i didn't know how long i was
going to be around i think the older i
get
the more detached i kind of have from
that thinking and that mindset
but you have to like something special
about kind of knowing that
you're not infinite you know in a sense
yeah i feel like you know i
you wanna it's crazy because there's
this whole camp of people right now that
want to live forever and i'm like yo
that's the most tragic thing
ever you ever see like an old person at
the grocery store and then they got like
the
i saw this dude he had some quarters in
like four dollars and he didn't have a
belt only after suspenders it just
looked painful
uh-huh i don't want to be 93 like yeah
it's just kind of like
i see life like an anthology series like
let it be a mini series let it end
i don't know man like it's already
something i thought was like nah i'm not
going to do it i mean maybe one day when
i get older
i like the kids the kids like me you
know i'm king of the kids around
but you know ask him he knows his kids
love me more than anybody yeah i keep it
fun i keep it light i watch the cartoons
i give them the pretzels when they're
not supposed to have them like you know
yeah i saw i'm i'm a good hang when it
comes to the children so you know maybe
one day i might
have my own but my kids are going to be
crazy so that's going to be
oh that's going to be a weird dynamic
it'll be dope bro i can't wait for you
to see it it's just it's just a cool
thing
you got to watch it because you
understand what you probably be dealing
with these kids are going to be out of
their mind
so you know have fun with them i love
the kids man shout out all the kids
so obviously this past year year and a
half has been crazy things are starting
to open up again
have you seen anything in this past year
that is making you
you know go into 21 and 22 and beyond
and go
look i absolutely have to do this has
there been anything kind of
life-changing in in this quarantine that
you want to things change from you know
a point of view but you know
everything's still the same you know
what i mean like you said it before it's
always existed
i think it's important to not miss the
moment and i think that's one thing that
i noticed from the pandemic because
people were so
highlighted on the money that we were
highlighting the small moments that we
had
not doing shows for a minute makes you
want to do these shows and one of these
people like
of course there's a lot of people that
you know that are regulars that come
around and like i always wondered like
how liz is doing like you know pete who
used to come to our show
early on he just got he just had his
baby you know i mean it's like and you
relations with people but it's like you
can't miss these moments because you
know you might not
get them again but make sure that even
if it's not the specific moment you know
when you get another moment
cherish it and try to live within it and
not kind of look past it that's it for
me
man like i felt the same way there's so
many things that
i got to do that i wasn't really having
fun while i was doing it i was so
stressed about
just doing it well and being able to
just make it that i didn't really
you know what i'm saying like don't i
don't even eat the food in the green
room i didn't i didn't
celebrate any of it you know being so
focused
and on thing which is a good thing
because it helps you get to where you
are yeah but like we were saying no one
cares about you
like they don't the fans don't
necessarily care
if you stumble on this song or they see
you stumble on this joke they just want
to see you
if you did one song and spent the rest
of the show talking to the audience
they'll say it was the best show they
had yo
so so straight up like if the best
artist that you're a fan of just did a
meet and greet that's really all they
all people they just want they want you
they want to meet billy eileen they want
you to know that they exist
and those are the moments that we're
speaking of you know you can't focus the
moment's not okay is this part of this
song and this is listening
now the moment is like the kid in the
front like that said that they love you
and they're crying
it's like what the [ __ ] are you crying
for like
you said i was like y'all they're so
weird like what's wrong with you people
that's like i wish i would have paid
attention more to those moments you know
like i played two coachellas like and i
don't remember anything before
i played coachella now and after i got
off stage i went home and i drove home
you got in your car you just drove home
you went to sleep in your bed yeah we
went home
that's hilarious well i got all day long
i probably should have kicked it for a
little bit
uh-huh well you know it's always the
next time
it's weird for me man this this year has
been wild in the sense that
a lot of my friends that i grew up with
a lot of people that i know um they're
hurting man
i remember older people would always
tell me nobody's coming to save you
this pandemic kind of showed me that
like nobody is coming to save you
at all the government won't come and
save you you probably will get fired
from your job
like what do you tell people because you
have so many fans that are like
in their early 20s and you know a lot of
the younger kids from my neighborhood is
like where i saw it the worst
and it's only because i'm going like
we're doing these things i'm going like
you know giving them groceries and like
helping their moms do certain stuff and
stuff like that
but i saw like the rapid growth of like
15 year olds just seeing them change
overnight and i'm telling you it took
like six months if i'm able to run up
like a 7 500
uber bill in two months just to keep you
from you know getting hurt i know if
it's 20 kids i could do that for it's
5 000 kids i can't you know what i mean
like right so what happened to those
kids we gave some money to um
this initiative where they were just
asking people for 500
to try to get wi-fi and computer access
to the kids in long beach who had to go
to school on zoom and it's like yeah
the fact that this is what these kids
have to do and a large percentage of
these kids don't even have access to
these things
and then the library's closed it's like
what do you expect
these kids to do and it's like you said
no one's coming to save them because the
school doesn't care if you don't have a
laptop they're not buying you one
i'm a mentor for this thing called the
boys club in new york basically it's a
club
five bucks a year if you're if you're a
young man you get to go there and you
have mentors and mentees kind of older
brothers
that um are there to help you with
homework
they got like a swimming pool it's crazy
it's awesome right
but one of the things that i'm trying to
teach them is so much of what i learned
in school
was complete garbage that had no
application
to where the world is like people are
like go to college
get college debt put your head down get
a job you know when my parents
immigrated here in 82 they were buying
into believing into that
and my biggest fear is i got a
three-year-old and a one-year-old i
don't know what to tell them what to
believe in
i was really like raised to never
believe any of that yeah like when i was
in the 10th grade now to my mom i'm
dropping out of high school she said
okay
and she understood so i had to leave too
yeah and it's like that's not regular
you know what i mean but
it's not remember we were on tour once i
was explaining a lot of people can't
believe that i didn't graduate from high
school
and i was telling you know corey that it
was a it was a
basic normal thing in california and
then we're in a room full of successful
musicians like people that are touring
and doing things
and then he asked us you know who
graduated from high school i think out
of
15 people it was like two people had
graduated high school and then we
started looking into the numbers and
seeing how broad it is like i think in
in in the city like
about um 40 40 44 to 45 percent of
cambodian kids drop out of high school
by the time they're 13. what's even
sadder than like never having belief is
like losing belief
so then you get to the point where
everyone's in the same pot and then we
start to fight each other because
everyone's unhappy
i have two competing things that i'm
trying to teach my kids
the way the world should be and the way
the world is
and there's this there's a gap in
between that and that's
my been my biggest challenge as a dad
my mom constantly apologizes to me
constantly oh i'm so sorry you got to
deal with this deal with this and in my
whole life i never once
had any gripes with my mother but it's
the reality of the situation
and i think if i wasn't taught reality
then i would be nowhere right now you
know you have to know where you sit in
life
you have to know how to get out of it
and i feel like in america we constantly
i don't want to know that we teach
we teach self-importance but also like
demeaning people like oh you should be
great but
you're worthless it's like that's what
we do to people and then you have people
far-reaching and trying that's why you
have such a strong celebrity culture and
all these other things like
yeah when bad things happen in the world
like people go to famous people would it
be like what should we do
and it's asking for we feel like yeah no
we're not special unless we above and
beyond
[Music]
thanks for sharing that you know being
open with me with us with everything
going on i think it's important for us
to try to connect more with each other
so
happy it could be me here yeah thanks
for taking the time bro
man i'll see you next time at dinner
with tommy yeah
and then we'll go from there sure
definitely i appreciate you yeah this is
one of my favorite things i've done so
i appreciate it cool thanks bro
[Music]
please use that tape that's the most
yeah that's that's the one that's the
most normal one
you don't use it i would be so upset
when i see